it's great to welcome to the program
today nicholas christakis sterling
professor of
social natural science at yale
university and also
author of apollo's arrow uh it's so
great to have you on i i'm glad
to be talking to you today david thank
you for having me
so there are so many things that we can
say
about the medical handling of this
global hundred-year pandemic
about governmental failures or successes
vaccine development
etc but one of the things that i find
interesting which you've talked about
are sort of the cultural aspects what we
learned and what was exposed maybe about
american culture
over the last nearly year of dealing
with the global pandemic
can you kind of frame that conversation
for us and explain what
what we should be thinking about when we
think about culture and the pandemic
right well i think you already
highlighted one important factor which
is
something i would lead with right away
which is this way that we have come to
live
in this last year and a lot of the
things that have happened
uh for example the death of health care
workers or
a lot of the denial and the lies that we
have seen about the pandemic
many many of these features seem so
unnatural and alien
but it's important to understand that
plagues are not new to our species
they're just new to us we think all of
these things are so
unusual and weird and unnatural and how
can we but that's just not true and in
fact
when you study the uh psychological
social and economic responses to the
covet 19 pandemic you see
that many of those responses um actually
have obtained
with pandemics and plagues going back
thousands of years
so let me give you a couple of examples
let me start with a really simple one
which is the death of health care
workers
many people are aware of the fact that
you know many hundreds of american
health care workers and thousands of
healthcare workers around the world
have died caring for patients who are
sick in fact one of the reasons we
should behave better is to reduce
our imposing risk on these people of
dying caring for us
well thucydides in the plague of athens
in 430 bc
talks about the death death of
healthcare workers pope clement vi
in the bubonic plague in 1347 talks
about the death of
nurses taking care of patients this is
not new
or lies in denial we've seen huge
amounts of like
superstitions about you know you could
use bleach to treat the condition or
or or like you know bill gates is going
to inject us the vaccine has you know
microchips it's ridiculous or um or
denial including at the former president
you know the white house saying it's
going away there's nothing happening
it's going away which was completely
false and
known to be false this also this
response
is typical of human beings during times
of plague
because we don't want to believe that
this bad thing is happening to us
and on and on i could go on i mean blame
for example the desire to blame
others is again very typical uh we we
saw this during bubonic plague when
there was anti-semitism you know the
jews were blamed uh
we saw it during hiv you know when when
gay people were blamed or haitians were
blamed or iv drug users were blamed
um there's always this desire to blame
someone else uh
when there's a time of plague anyway i
could go on but there are these
these things that are happening to us or
i'll say one more thing and then i'll
shut up
you know the uh you know there's a lot
of misunderstanding
about what is happening to us in terms
of the economy for example
yes so people think that the economy is
collapsing because of what the state
what the government is doing to us
but if you read accounts of plagues
going back thousands of years for
example
uh uh uh john of ephesus a priest
writing about the plague of justinian in
500 a.d talks about how the economy
collapses
everything slowed and ceased people were
not out and about
there was no government that was
ordering schools or businesses to close
in that period it's just
this is what the virus does it's it
stops social interactions which
therefore stops the economy
so all of these things that we're seeing
are a once in a century event and we
just i think have to accept that and
maturely confront it you know i um i
interviewed
brian greene during the pandemic earlier
in the pandemic
and one of the things he pointed out was
that
he thinks there's a certain naivete
thinking that if we were to make contact
with intelligent alien species all of
our
our earthly problems would all of a
sudden seem
sort of quaint and irrelevant and we
would come together as a
as a global people because now this
thing that transcends
our problems has taken place he thinks
even that is probably
naive to think that there would be some
initial if
instinct of that and very quickly we
would go back to our normal problems
is there a similar naivete and i think
the answer clearly is yes as evidenced
by the last many months
to think that something like this would
have allowed us to cross the partisan
bickering
and not to devolve into the same sort of
uh arguments the politically aligned
arguments that we see with abortion and
taxes and so many of these other things
is it just fundamentally naive to think
that something like a global pandemic
would
cross those bridges well first of all
let me back up and say there's a very
famous exchange between i think it was
president ronald reagan and and um
mikhail gorbachev
where uh reagan says to they're having
an exchange about how they can work
together
and uh reagan says well let me ask you
you know if the earth was invaded by
aliens would you come to our defense
and gorbachev says of course you know
and uh
so this this trope this idea that's in
science fiction movies that human beings
would come together
uh to confront a shared threat
is uh actually deeply fundamental and
there's another very famous
social psychology experiment or
demonstration called the robbers cave
demonstration which was taken which took
place in the 1950s where
um 12 11 or 12 year old boys were taken
into a summer camp and divided into two
groups
yeah and uh and then they were their
group solidarity was fostered and then
it was revealed that there was this
other group nearby and then group
competition was fostered
and then the investigators contrived to
have a shared threat
and show that now having created these
divisions they could undo the divisions
the shared threat was they contrived to
have the water supply to the camp
interrupted
so the boys had to work together across
groups you know to fix the problem
so so there's all this background on
exactly the topic that you're mentioning
and it is true that a shared threat can
bind groups together
and many people have for years thought
that a virus or a germ would have that
effect in other words
we all are human we're all facing this
deadly threat
we should uh work together to confront
it
but there are few features of play of of
epidemics and this one in particular
that make that hard
my guess is my guess is one is that not
everybody agrees us to the nature of the
threat
first and partly that's because this
this germ
serious and deadly though it is is not
as deadly as
thank god it could have been just to be
clear we could have been facing a
bubonic plague type situation
right now on the planet and many people
you need to people need to understand
this it's just by the luck of god that
we're not facing something that's
10 or 30 times deadlier like in the
movie contagion anyway this particular
pathogen is serious it kills about one
percent of the people that get symptoms
from it but it's not so deadly
as smallpox or bubonic plague which i
think would have galvanized
public interest and maybe helped us
transcend some of our political
divisions
first point second the the germs
struck us at a particularly vulnerable
moment in the life of our society
in terms of our intellectual life we
have as a nation
lost respect for science we have we have
politicized the notion of expertise we
think that experts are elites who are
trying to take advantage of us
rather than just experts you know like
if you have a car problem
i don't think i'm as good as my car
mechanic in figuring out what the
problem is i
want to pay someone who knows more than
i do about the problem and if you have a
surgeon or anything else
there's expertise in the world or a
plumbing disaster there's expertise in
the world
so but we have begun to politicize this
notion of expertise to our detriment
we have high levels of political
polarization and economic inequality
already century high levels when the
virus struck and
finally we have lost the capacity for
nuance
in our civil civic discourse
people say oh you're with me or you're
against me or things are black or white
but adults know that that's
not true things are not black or white
most things are shades of gray anyway
all of those things plus the relatively
low
but still high level of death from this
germ
have made it difficult for us to band
together to confront it
plus i think frankly incompetent
leadership in the former administration
at the white house which minimized the
threat and did not
act to protect the public interest i'll
say one more thing and then i'll shut up
again
many people say well okay trump didn't
do so well but you know what about the
england or
italy or other countries it's true many
other countries also did poorly
but many countries did well and not just
rich islands like taiwan and new zealand
germany did well greece did well you
know we're the united states of america
i expected more from us i expected us to
do well
in confronting this threat yeah rwanda
is also an interesting example actually
of a country that that that did uh
quite well certainly better than many
might have imagined if they didn't know
that much about uh about rwanda
when when we think about the next year
um
a lot of the discussions are when will
herd immunity be reached but there's
some pretty interesting pieces that
suggest that the
what might be called the cultural end to
the pandemic will come before
the medical end of the pandemic
particularly if the most at risk
are vaccinated first as is happening and
the deaths go down dramatically so
there's kind of a question as to whether
the cultural and the medical ends will
coincide
what are you looking for in terms of
this next year when you look at
the cultural impact the rollout of
vaccinations the transition to a new
federal administration handling this
well i think you you're highlighting the
key issues there's this notion of herd
immunity
which is this idea that a population can
be immune to a condition
or immune to having an epidemic of the
condition
even if not everyone within the
population is immune let's understand
and and through various calculations and
making an
accommodation for something known as the
network effects probably at least 50
percent of americans have to have
acquired immunity to the condition
before we get hurt immunity now
when that happens the virus is not gone
it still circulates and can kill people
but
we've taken the wind out of its sails
it's epidemic force has been
nullified when we get to this critical
threshold now
we have miraculously invented a vaccine
we're the first generation of humans to
confront the ancient threat of plagues
that has been capable to develop a
specific countermeasure in real time
it's amazing but as we're all seeing in
the news we have to
manufacture hundreds of millions of
doses distribute them which is not easy
and persuade people to take them and i
think it'll take at least a year before
we get to 50 percent
or more which is what we really need
vaccination at least 50
meanwhile the virus is still spreading
about 14 of americans are infected so
far
this has a long runway so either way i
think it's going to take another year
before we reach herd immunity and during
that time we're going to have to live in
a changed world with
wearing masks with periodic school and
business closures with
gathering bands with extra hygiene and
all of the headaches that we've come to
be familiar with
and this is before the emergence of new
more communicable strains
which is another complication so i think
at least a year and then
we'll enter the um the intermediate
period where
some of the things that you mentioned
we'll begin to obtain which is we're
going to have to begin to confront the
psychological social and economic
aftershocks
because let's not forget tens of
millions of americans are out of work
millions of people have lost uh
businesses have closed millions of
children have lost schooling
there's a disability many several
hundred
probably two and a half million
americans will be disabled by this
condition
between half a million and a million
will die so we're going to have a lot of
recovery to do and i think it'll take a
while but come 2024
approximately these are approximate i
think we'll finally enter the
post-pandemic period
and then i think it'll be like the
roaring 20s of the 20th century after
the 1918 influenza pandemic
will have a roaring 20s of the of the
21st century yeah one of the things that
i've not seen discussed that much which
i think is important and interesting is
i i never beli at the time when in may
donald trump was saying
the measures that some want you to take
are more damaging than the virus
itself i thought that was dangerous and
a disaster but
i do think that there is a an aspect of
this which is
after a year or a year and a half or
however long it is of this feeling that
the world outside of your house is
hostile and dangerous to you
seeing two people close to each other
with no masks looks
like an act of something more than what
it used to be right this
stuff becomes ingrained that doesn't get
undone
in a month or in two months and i'm i'm
curious as to what the long-term
group psychology impacts of that are
going to be that's exactly right uh
that's what i was suggesting that
when we get to early 2022 we'll finally
have put the biological and
epidemiological impact
of the virus behind us but there's still
going to be a lot of psychological and
other recovery that'll take a couple of
years
judging again from the also the history
of past epidemics just like you said
not everyone's going to take off their
mask a year from now right
for a variety of reasons people are
going to still be wearing masks some
will be cautious the virus will still be
around
uh other people will have
immunodeficiency some people will have
habits they'll be worried etc
so it's not going to be instantaneous
nor will any of the other recovery be
instantaneous it's going to be a long
and
enduring shock i think what people need
to understand is is we happen to be
alive
like our grandparents were alive when
the world was at war
right like when i talked to my uh greek
relatives in greece about this in their
80s
their frame of reference is not like the
typical american
it's it's like a european who's used to
having invading armies my my father
remembers the nazis invading athens
when he was a boy so for him you know
that was like a once in a century event
and now this is another once in a
century event you know
so so i think people need to understand
that
that this is a quite a serious and
unusual experience to us
again for humans have been you know
plagues are in in the bible they're in
shakespeare
they're in homer they're in cervantes
you know there's nothing new about
plagues per se but
for us it's quite a new experience and
we have to understand
much as we wish that this had not
happened to us and much as we wish that
it would end
quickly it's not it's just not what
plagues do
uh we've been speaking with nicholas
christakis who
is sterling professor of social natural
science at yale university
also author of apollo's arrow i so
appreciate your time today
david thank you so much for having me